let's now tackle Part C which tells us
40 is less than 10 an alternate model
for the internal temperature of the
potato at time T minutes is the function
G that satisfies the differential
equation the derivative of G with
respect to T is equal to the negative of
G minus 27 to the 2/3 power where G of T
is measured in degrees Celsius and G of
0 is equal to 91 find an expression for
G of T based on this model what is the
internal temperature of the potato at
time T is equal to 3 so they gave us a
differential equation they want us to
find an expression for G of T so
essentially find a solution to this
differential equation and then they want
to use that solution to find the
internal temperature at time T equals 3
so the first thing to appreciate with
this is in an AP calculus class and so
if they're asking us to solve a
differential equation or find a solution
to a differential equation it is
unlikely to be a really strange
differential equation it's likely to be
a separable differential equation and
then once we find that solution we have
to evaluate it at time T is equal to 3
so let's rewrite the differential
equation and then let's try to evaluate
let's see if we can find a solution and
then we'll evaluate the derivative of G
with respect to t is equal to the
negative of g minus 27 to the 2/3 power
so if this is going to be a separable
differential equation I want to separate
the VG and the DT so I'm going to treat
my differentials like numbers so or
variables so I'm going to multiply both
sides times the T differential and so
then I am going to have the capital G
differential DG is equal to negative
times G minus 27 to the 2/3 power Det
and the whole notion here I'm trying to
get all of the G things on the side with
the DG and then all the things that
involve T on the side with the DT so we
don't see any T's here so we really just
have to get the G's over on this side
while leaving the DT there and then we
can integrate both sides
so let's see if we were to divide both
sides by G minus 27 to the 2/3 G minus
27 to the 2/3 G minus 27 to the 2/3 what
do we have well we can rewrite the left
side as G minus 27 to the negative 2/3
negative 2/3 D G is equal to I'm left
with just this negative DT is equal to
negative DT now let's see now we can or
actually just a simplified or just to
make it a little bit more obvious I
could write that as negative 1 DT and
now we just have to integrate both sides
so we could rewrite this as let me write
an integral sign I'm going to integrate
I'm going to integrate both sides here
and so what is this going to give me
well on the left side here you could try
to do some use substitution saying U is
equal to G minus 27 and then D u would
be D G or you might recognize that look
the derivative of G minus 27 is just B G
the derivative of G minus 27 is just
going to be equal to 1 so you could even
say hey look I have my I have the
derivative there so I could really
integrate with respect to G minus 27 and
so really I would just use the reverse
power rule I would take my G minus 27
I would increment this exponent by 1 so
C negative 2/3 plus 1 is positive 1/3 so
positive 1/3 power and then I would
divide by this new exponent so dividing
by 1/3 is the same thing as multiplying
by 3 so that's the left-hand side this
is going to be equal to the right-hand
side this is just going to be negative T
and for good measure I'm going to have a
plus C right over here so how can we
solve for C well they give us some
information they say G of 0 is equal to
91 so
to write that down so when T is zero G
is 91 so we can write let me write it
over here so three times so when T is
zero G is 91 91 minus 27 to the 1/3
power is equal to negative T well now
we're saying T is zero so we could write
negative zero there or we could just not
write it and then plus C so that's what
C is going to be equal to LC 91 minus 27
is 64 64 to the 1/3 power is positive 4
and so we have C is equal to 12 C is
equal to 12 and let's see we want to
write an expression for G of T so now
let's just manipulate this and solve for
G so if we so let me just take this and
go right over here so if we divide both
sides by 3 we are going to get G minus
27 to the 1/3 power is equal to negative
T over 3 plus 4 I just divide both sides
by 3 now I can take the cube of both
sides and I would get G minus 27 is
equal to negative T over 3 plus 4 to the
third power and I just have to add 27 to
both sides and I'll make it clear G is a
function of T is equal to negative T
over 3 plus 4 all of that to the third
power plus 27 so I did the first part
this is let me not crossed it this right
over here is an expression for G of T it
was indeed a separable differential
equation it took a little bit of
algebraic manipulation to get us there
but we were able to do it we were not
only able to solve for the general
solution we're able to find a particular
solution using this initial condition
right over here that G of 0 is equal to
91 now we'll do the easy part based on
this model what is the internal
temperature of the potato at time T
equals 3 so G of 3 is equal to negative
3
over three plus four I'm just write out
negative three over three plus four to
the third power plus 27 well this is
negative one so negative one plus four
is three so this is three to the third
power which is 27 plus 27 is equal to 54
degrees Celsius and we are done